certaines sont des chanteuses à voix
elle c'est plutôt une chanteuse à
franges si elle n'a derrière elle que
trois ans de carrière solo et deux
albums au succès fulgurant elle a déjà
remporté deux victoires de la musique et
fait déjà partie des plus grandes ne
serait ce que pour son mètre
quatre-vingt deux sous son sein la
grenade clara luciani est en aparté
bonjour clara le chien ni bonjour
bienvenue dans un aparté a dit dans ces
jolis jeux vont
écouter tant mieux on ira avec ça vous
plaise je vous en prie
vous pouvez descendre les quelques
marches et vous imprégner des lieux
c'est très beau ça vous plaît la déroute
sanglant mélange des genres
c'est très joli vous aller repérer sans
doute quelques touches de votre carrière
de votre existence des clins d'oeil une
vue oliveux mulhouse cette vue là par
exemple un vrai c'est magnifique je
rêverais d'avoir ça qu'un bus la sainte
victoire c'est la sainte-victoire votre
sainte victoire sourit de la provence un
chef-d'oeuvre de la nature avec
barbarella palois ont fleuri une
influence aussi complètement cette femme
libérée c'est magnifique
croix saint croyants jettent tout ou
près les folios vous avez trouvé
enquêter longuement de manière très
pointue et on espère vous surprendre
comme ça tout au long de l'émission on
est content que dès les premières
minutes vous soyez troublée par des
petits éléments comme ça je vais vous
proposer si vous le voulez bien vous
installé sur le canapé derrière vous il
est jaune ce une couleur très sixties
d'ailleurs non on va là dedans alors
j'ai dit clara luciani très sûr de moi
j'ai bien fait il ya un puzzle c'est
génial oui oui vous avez bien fait c'est
évidemment pas la façon la plus corse de
prononcer mon nom mais en fait
je me suis rendu compte que que les gens
avaient du mal à le dire ce nom là et
beaucoup de gens au départ qui
m'appelait même luchini alors bon j'ai
décidé de simplifier la prononciation et
la forêt prononciation et clara luciani
le
monde ou presque ont pas le il en fait
on va s'entraîner promis
c'est la traduction c'est la petite
lumière clara c'est la clarté clara et
solaire c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu se
passer des lumières à vous seul vous
illuminer les en gros vous passer car en
bon vous mais c'est vrai et puis les
disques évidemment chaque titre est un
succès aux presque si vous êtes bien
installé je vous propose d'ores et déjà
qu'on en parle et que vous me racontiez
un petit peu qui vous êtes moi je sais
en tout cas que vous êtes aux tris
compositrice interprète
29 en trois ans de carrière en solo
seulement et déjà deux albums de succès
deux victoires de la musique un tube et
coûter 100 millions de fois devenu un
hymne de féministes est-ce que même vous
vous ne trouvez pas que les choses vont
vite très vite
alors je dirais pas ça nous concernant
parce que
je suis arrivé à paris à l'âge de 19 ans
donc à 10 ans maintenant et ses amis
beaucoup de temps en fête a démarré j'ai
enchaîné beaucoup de petits boulots j'ai
même eu des moments en fait je me suis
dit que peut-être ce n'était pas fait
pour moi et que j'allais pas y arriver
j'ai appelé mes parents je leur ai dit
je vais revenir je vais reprendre les
études ça va ça va jamais marcher donc
j'ai eu des doutes et non c'était
c'était plutôt long par contre là où
vous avez raison c'est qu'une fois que
la grenade a commencé à passer à la
radio est là tout s'est accéléré la
grenade et coûter 100 millions de fois
ça donne le tournis ça donne le vertige
nous on a envie quand même d'être les
100 millionième est un oui c'est pas
joli message
[Musique]